Hi my name is Nomaguchi from Gourmet Innovation. Thank you for coming today.
First things first, I would like to talk about the service Takumen.com.
When you say Ramen, the first thing people think of is Cup noodles or those often sold at supermarkets.
For example, those sold at the supermarket that uses a famous ramen shop such as "Ippudo" in their packaging with the catchphrase "Experience the exact taste as the famous restaurant”.
These products sold at the supermarket are basically soup made at the factory that imitates the flavor of the ramen.
Most of them are the types where you would dilute the flavor with hot water.
The biggest distinction Takumen.com has with its ramen is
that the concepts lies on delivering the ramen exactly from the restaurant to the consumer's doorstep.
What this means is that, and this isn't a joke or anything
but we put the soup from the restaurant in a special bag
and put the chashuu from the restaurant in a bag, and we freeze this, and send it to your house.
The same goes with the noodles, we freeze the ones they serve at the restaurant.
With the delivered frozen soup and chashuu
you can boil water and let it defreeze like what you would do with a Bon Curry.
When you put the ingredients in there and warm it up, the soup defrosts and it will get warm.
When this happens, of course, you will be able to enjoy the exact same soup you have at the restaurant.
What we still struggle with up to this day, is that when we explain "It is the exact taste as the restaurant”.
People think that it is the same as frozen products where they imitate the taste and sell at the super market
but the products we deliver are, in all truth, is ramen that the restaurant owner or the staff actually make.
Currently, our Takumen.com website only offers ramen from about 100 famous ramen restaurants from Hokkaido up north to Kyushuu down south.
From here, we store the frozen products sent from the ramen shops at our refrigerating warehouse in Hamamatsu Shizuoka, and stock it there.
When the end user clicks to make a purchase at the Takumen.com site, when you click by 9AM, it will be delivered to your house as early as the following day.
You can say it is very primitive, and we don't use the newest technology, and our name does say Takumen.com but we are not an IT company.
It is simply a company that started with one simple idea.
I would like to talk about how we started out the company.
I originally worked at a hotel overseas, and after returning to Japan, I opened a restaurant.
After this, about 10 years, I had 3 restaurants. I still have them today.
I unexpectedly met with my batch mate from middle school and high school.
This guy was the so-called IT guy. He was there ever since the start up of Cyber Agent when there were only 5 people
After this he became a director at Traffic Gate, and when they were bought by Rakuten, right when he was thinking of quitting, we happen to meet up
When we were talking about what he would do after, we talked about the business model of Takumen.com and I instantly thought it was a fun idea
After about 3 days this, we prepared to start the company, and within 2 weeks of meeting again, we registered the company. This was in 2010 when we started the company
without any strategy or thinking about our chances of succeeding, with just the idea, and our optimism, we started a company in 2010.
After this, sorry my story goes back and forth.
When I was running my restaurant business, it is different from the products that everyone does.
It isn't the kind of business where leverage is effective, and it is a labor intensive business.
And the profit it makes can only go up so much, and economies of scale does not work on it very well either.
It is a type of business where when you make a mistake, the already small profit can all disappear.
During this time, when I looked at IT companies, I would envy them while I looked at their financial statement.
During this time, I was running 3 restaurants, and when I opened my fourth one called Sakurajousui, I had to close it after about a year.
At the beginning, it was featured on TC, and had some popularity, and it was thriving for a bit, but suddenly customers stopped coming, and the store closed in a year.
I spent about 10 million yen on this business.
What I thought about it was, other people would resign from work, and ask for money from their relatives or borrow money from many different places to collect the 10 million yen
they would start a shop with the 10 million yen they worked hard to collect, but a lot of them would have to close their places.
For myself, the 10 million that I spent for a store I closed was through a company, but I felt that there would be people who felt that their life ends when they go through this
because it is a kind of business where when you get the location wrong, there is no way to turn things around.
Even if you think that you can succeed, once you open, even when you start thinking "maybe I could have done this like this", it is an industry where you cannot get that back.
What I vaguely thought of at the time was that I wanted to help restaurant who had the aspiration to serve delicious food and were serious about their craft
even when they fail at their location, they will still be able to sell their product.
So when I met up with Inoue who was my batchmate, when I heard the idea, I instantly thought it was an incredible idea.
First, we had to choose a place that was very hard for others to overcome.
What we thought of was that in the world, there were people who had the ambition to work really hard to create really good ramen for people to enjoy.
And a lot of them would not succeed just because of mismatch in location or were not able to get into trends.
What I instantly felt was that, as cliché as it sounds, I wanted to shed light to them and help them in a positive way
and at this moment I wanted to do it.
This was the catalyst.
And as I have said, from the hotel to running a restaurant, I was the epitome of anti IT.
When we started Takumen.com, a lot of people from the IT industry found our company interesting, and would visit our office.
What I thought back then was how different type of species we were.
For example, they would be googling things on their computer while making conversation, and at 2010, it wasn't something that I have ever done.
I was extremely anti-IT that I was culture shocked and thought "Why would you go on a computer while you talk to another person”.
Then I started to be influenced, and people in the restaurant business were not like that, and I would be wearing a suit, and make conversation while doing something on my computer
and Ramen shop owners would see me that way.
They would start treating me as an IT being.
I still don't know much about IT, but at that time I was very culture shocked.
I would try to always put dotcom in the service.
This was the kind of level I started off at.
We really just created a company with an idea.
We weren't even thinking about how we would freeze the ramen, or who would do it, or even the logistics of it
or how we would make the website, we did had not decided on anything.
Every night, we would just drink and talk, and before you know it had already been a month.
At the beginning, looking back, it was like a big joke.
We would rent a truck go around to ramen shops, and we would get a whole pot of soup, and we would go to a garage and we would try to make ramen.
we had no plan at all.
while we were doing this, we were gonna do this, we were just gonna do this.
This may sound self glorifying but Inoue, the IT guy, and I had a very interesting chemistry.
I was an extreme old school sales person.
On the other hand, Inoue was an extreme introvert.
He wasn't very good at talking to other people, but he was at the top of his game when it came to marketing and IT.
I think it was most interesting for two people that were extreme opposites to come together and create a service.
First off, I asked Inoue to create the site, and let him handle that, but of course with the help of outsourced resources.
I kept on talking to Ramen shops first off, I asked Inoue to create the site, and let him handle that, but of course with the help of outsourced resources.
what I did was, I kept on talking to ramen shops.
I assume everyone has a certain image of ramen shop owners
but to be honest this image is true, and they are very intimidating.
A lot of them were in gangs before, and there are those we collaborate with that would say vulgar things, and they are very intimidating.
I personally don't like fights, and I was very scared when selling the business to them.
What a lot of people that I talked to about the business model are surprised about is that
how was I able to convince these ramen shops.
I didn't have anything special
I simply made a list and called all of them from top to bottom.
Some would shout at me over the phone whilst I ask them 5 minutes of their time.
I didn't have the experience of getting physically hit, but there were shouting, a lot of shouting actually.
Hardship stories I have during the start up of the company was going to meet with intimidating ramen shop owners everyday.
Of course, I also tried creative ways to approach them, such as going in as customer.
After doing this, I would eat 7 to 8 bowls of ramen in a day, and would make exaggerated faces to show how much I enjoyed the ramen to make the owners feel good.
I would then slowly and passionately talk to them
then they would agree to try out the service, and from there we increased numbers.
Up to this day, the most memorable tie was probably that we didn't even have a website or brochures but just verbally sold the service to them.
I would just randomly show up, and some would tell me to go home, but I would go back the next day.
A lot of people in the ramen industry
used to be in gangs back in their day, and they are very scary, but once you become friendly with them, they take very good care of you.
It sounds like an impossible job, but there are a lot of them that shout
or when they are not in the mood would break their promises.
But slowly, I think because it helped that my style in selling matched with them.
We would passionately talk about society, and they would tell me that I was a good person, this is how we slowly got them to join.
We opened the website.
The company started in April, so the website was opened around July.
At this time, we had 5 ramen shops registered.
How we did it was we called up Rakuten sites that sold a similar kind of straight soup.
What this is is that they were doing it by themselves, so we told them to sell it to us.
What we noticed during this time, was Ramen shops is about the brand.
What it is is that famous ramen has their branding.
For example, for brands that have long waiting lines and become successful
the owner gains confidence, then they would open a second shop.
All of a sudden, even if you are selling the same thing, the customers would start to say that it doesn't taste as good, that it would not taste the same if it wasn't something that the owner made it himself.
In conclusion, it is a very rare type of business where the more you increase the number of stores, the more you shed off the brand.
It is very hard to expand.
The branding of each store is very strong
but, let's say, it is very hard to sell all over the country with simply the brand.
I'm not sure how many are ramen enthusiasts here but
in the 100 stores that Takumen sells in, I don't think there are a lot of people who know this but
even if you know famous ones such as Ippudo or Ichiran, for example, there is a store in Shinjuu called Fuunji that specializes in tsukemen, and up to today, it still takes up to 1 hour lining up, but I think a lot of people still don't know about it.
When you think about this, we collect the brands, and use this brand to gather customers.
Each one is weak, but once you get them together, it can make an interesting business.
At the beginning, there wasn't a plan or anything
but slowly, things built up
and now, we gather a lot of famous stores.
A lot of them have very strong brands
and from there, the website's strength to attract customers grew.
Ramen shops as individuals are not very effective
but when we gather them together, this is something that we can do
and it something that we gradually achieved.
It seems boastful, but it isn't as if we make a lot of profit.
The first time we did it, it was actually very similar to the business that I had struggled in the past where it is very labor-intensive.
The first time we started, it was like that.
Up to now, it isn't that we are an IT company.
We still have the sales representatives use a phone and talk to individual stores use old school methods.
But, after 6 years, something happened that we never thought would at the beginning.
There have been shops that call us up and tell us they want to be on Takumen, I wouldn't say it happens everyday, but it happens often.
But we actually only feature famous stores, so we have turned them down.
We have to tell them that "we don't want you", but lately, it's been something hard to do.
We always think of how we will turn them down, and what I often do is, I tell them we get a lot of inquiries and we want to talk to each one of them and tell them to wait.
We tell very vaguely, and we take up time and just wait out until they forget about it.
A failure story we had at the beginning, well, it is more of a hardship than a failure.
As mentioned earlier, was to gather ramen shops.
The next thing was that I only had experience in the restaurant business
and I had never worked at an start-up.
My partner Inoue, saw Cyber Agent grow from a start-up with 5 people to becoming a top player
even with Traffic Gate which I didn't know about
had a large expansion with they started up.
This is the kind of experience he had, and I looked up to Inoue who had quite the experience with startups.
I always thought of startups as cool, and I fantasized about telling my friends of being in a startup
and this is actually partially why I started one
and to my surprise, Inoue started recruiting people one after the other, telling me this is the way of the startup world.
In the restaurant business, how much you can lower the fixed cost you had would impact how much you could increase the very little profit you made.
Apparently, in the startup world, it was common knowledge that the more you brought in talented individuals, the higher your profit would be.
Then I thought, alright, and went along with recruiting people.
People found the combination of ramen and not really IT individuals, but let's say, the combination of ramen and the internet interesting.
One of the reasons behind Takumen's popularity is that we didn't have money to spend on marketing, and we weren't able to advertise.
So what Inoue did was
2010 was a time when Twitter became popular and a lot of people were on it
what he did was he started to research on Takumen on Twitter.
He started a marketing strategy by calling up people who Tweeted about Takumen
and this was a strange way
but once he did that, we had an office in Shibuya,
people started spreading that if you Tweet about Takumen, you would get to eat free ramen.
The circle became bigger, and even famous Presidents of companies found interest in it.
After about half a year since starting the company, we would have business owners come in everyday.
Some would be sketchy middle aged men too.
So, once we did this marketing of making ramen at the office, and having them Tweet about how good it was.
Although we didn't spend a dime on it, the word just spread.
Most likely, this is the most rare phenomenon we had
with this, since I believed in the startup myth that Inoue told me about profits increasing if you hire talented people
and the more Tweets about Takumen and people coming to the office
a lot of people who were talented and experienced wanted to work at Takumen.
It is unbelievable, there were people that graduated from Tokyo University and worked at Accenture and wanted to work for us.
S lot of them wanted to make Takumen bigger and let people know about it.
We then recruited them one after the other.
I started to worry if this was a good move
but in actuality, it was not good at all
and it didn't have anything to do with being a startup.
I am not trying to brag, but our sales was barely hitting the 1 million mark
and we had 9 people
but Inoue said that startups are like this, at the beginning you would wait it out, and eventually it will hit it big.
And whilst I was being convinced by this, we were losing a lot of money
even when we kept on valuating and increasing our funds
we lost about 4 million yen a month.
just like that, we lost money.
I said, "we only made 1 million this month, we have a deficit of 4 million, what are we going to do?”
Then the IT guy says, "we will be fine"
but It wasn't fine.
When we realized we would lose the company if we didn't do something
we largely shrunk our size.
The freezing warehouse that we were outsourcing
the one we used to store the ramen we were sent
we would do "picking" ourselves
which is basically packing the products.
We were initially outsourcing this part of sending them to the customers
but since we didn't have the money, we decided to do it ourselves.
We bought a large freezer in a warehouse in Koto-ward
and we would go there.
The first thing we would do was change in our ski wear
go into the freezer that was minus 20 degrees
and it was a level where you would probably die if you stayed in it too long.
Even with the ski wear, we would wear a helmet.
First, when we go in the morning, we would take the orders, and put it in boxes ourselves.
The boxes would be then taken by the delivery company
and then taken to the customer.
At this time, since Takumen was already quite known
we would put things like "Delivery Center" or "Freezing Center"
as if we had an actual division that took care of the freezer.
We would also write "Customer Center" even though we would only have 1 telephone, and we all took turns in answering calls.
There were only about 3 or 4 people, and we did everything.
We managed to survive
that was when we realized this is what a startup is.
Well it was too late at the time, and we were just taking it one step at a time
we were even wondering if we would survive.
But by just working diligently, we realized that profits do go up
and it really did go up little by little.
As of now, the numbers aren't that high
but in a day we would get 300 orders, 200, 300, or 400 orders.
It might be a small number
but with just a fantasy that was between friends turned into something where people buy.
This was something very pleasing.
Up to now, we still want as many people as possible to enjoy eating through Takumen.
We still need to work hard.
I've cut out a lot of things
but lastly, I would like to talk about the the value of Takumen.com
what our strength in the business is.
In Japan, there are about 40,000 ramen shops
4000 shops that is 10% close each year, and another 10% open
in a year, there is a shifting of 4000 shops.
There is no other industry like this
There are 40,000 shops and including cup noodles the market size is 700 billion.
I'm not sure about the numbers.
there are 700 billion, I think 700 billion.
The restaurant that has the top share
I don't know if you call it a ramen shop
is Korakuen who sells 290 yen ramen.
It takes up to 20 to 30 billion.
The top share in a market size of 700 billion industry is 20 billion.
What does this mean?
We later realized that the ramen industry does not have a federator.
What this means is that it is a collection of individual shops.
The collection of individual shops is the ramen industry.
It means there isn't a big player.
We didn't really mean this to happen at the beginning.
When we realized that the ramen industry did not have a big player, there isn't anyone that doesn't know Takumen.
It maybe an exaggeration
but it is very well recognized.
What this means is that, for the first time, we had federated the ramen industry.
Famous ramen shops, ramen shops that have long lines.
I don't think there is anyone else that makes it easy to contact these places other than us.
It is something we didn't expect, we just worked hard on selling and before we knew it, it just became this big.
We realized it had great value.
Why did we realize this? Because we started getting calls from overseas.
We would receive emails from a rich person from Dubai
and they would say that they wanted to bring Japanese ramen to their place, but they don't know how to start.
What it meant was from foreign countries
they are very interested in ramen
but they don't know who to talk to about it
because there isn't a big player, and there wasn't a company that federated them.
When they started doing their research they stumbled upon Takumen
they said that it looked like it connected a lot of ramen stores.
At the beginning, inquiries like this would come once in a while
then it came from different parts of the world.
What we realized was that Japanese ramen was really popular.
Another thing was that we became the first federators.
Sorry but I’ll talk for 5 more minutes.
But we’ve brought some frozen ramen from Takumen.
There maybe some people who are already full but
we weren't sure how many people would come.
so please those who win rock, paper scissors can eat them.
How many people do we have here?
About 10 you can probably divide 1 into 2.
There is 4 for each, we have 4 each of tsukemen and ramen, and there are 8 of them.
What should we do, maybe ladies can eat first?
Or I think we might actually have more than enough.
Please if you like, eat some before it gets too soft. I'll finish in about 5 more minutes.
Please take some for those who want to try.
You can just take a bite and leave the rest.
What I wanted you to understand here is that
it is a completely different product from the diluted soup sold in the super market.
Please just take a bite and experience it.
To continue from earlier,
we received a lot of offers from around the world, and when we realized our strength of being the federator in the industry
we came up with starting overseas.
And we actually started 3 stores in Singapore.
What kind of ramen stores are they?
In one shop you can enjoy the ramen from famous ramen shops.
We have a small ramen museum like place over there.
This doesn't even exist in Japan.
The reason is, it is very hard to make the soup
then to make 7 types of soup cannot be done in 1 shop.
But we have a central kitchen, and here we can make up to 7 types of soup, and we heat it up at the shop before serving.
The owner of these 7 types of Japanese famous ramen shops give us the recipe for their ramen.
The recipe is only second to their life, and they actually share it with us.
The reason is, regardless of how famous one ramen store is
it is hard for them to expand overseas.
To open a shop, overseas is very difficult to achieve
but we can go overseas on their behalf.
When we tell them that we will make it for them if they share the recipe
what they tell us is "if it's with Takumen then we will”.
I'm not quite sure how far I can share but
we ask them without spending the initial cost.
This is actually unbelievable because we are able to ask for the recipe of ramen shops for free.
This is something that we can do because of our position we take.
Currently, we are slowly spreading the model of serving 7 different ramen from famous ramen shops in one place.
After Singapore, next is Vietnam, then we go to Thailand, America, and then Europe.
We aspire to spread this model all over the world.
Currently, we do business overseas and locally in Nihonbashi.
Our vision for the future is that we want to be ramen kings.
We go by the motto of becoming the ramen kings in the world, and we would like to take up different challenges around the world.
My story ends here.